عضو القياده المركزيه لحزبكم للكردستانيه
الايرانيه المعارض شكرا لقبولك الحديث
معنا
شكرا لكم اهلا وسهلا بكم وتحياتي لجمهوركم
سيد عبد الله
الايراني الكرديه المعارض تغيرت مبادئه
وافكاره من الماركسيه وصولا الان لمطالب
الديمقراطيه والعلمانيه بالاضافه الى
مطالب اخرى كيف وصلتم الى هذه المرحله اما
لا يا استاذه
حزبه شين نحن حزب يعمل من اجل العداله
الاجتماعيه وايضا نحن حزب كردي في كردستان
الايرانيه نحن نعمل من اجل حقوق الشعب
الكردي في كردستان الايرانيه من خلال عمل
الحزب نريد ان يصل شعبنا الى الحريات
والعداله والمساواه وحقوق المراه السلطات
الايرانيه حينما تتحدث عنكم كاحزاب معارضه
كوم لتحديدا
وديمقراطي الكردستانيه الايراني كذلك تقول
انكم احزاب انفصاليه
وتقول كذلك انكم ذراع اسرائيليه امريكيه
لضرب ايران كيف تردون على هذه التهمه
حزبكوا كردستان نعتقد ان للشعب الكردي
الحق في الحكم في وطنه لكن هذا ليس مدرجا
حاليا على الاجنده السياسيه لحزبنا اجنده
حزبنا واضحه اذا اعتزمنا تكوين حزب
انفصالي فسنذكر ذلك في برامج حزبنا نناضل
للوصول الى كردستان فيدراليه داخل حدود
ايران الفيدراليه لطالما اتهمت جمهوريه
ايران الاسلاميه معارضيها بانهم كفار
واعداء للامه واتهمات اخرى من اجل تدبير
قمعها وطهادها تجريم احزاب المعارضه له
اشكال مختلفه حيث شهدنا الهجمات في
كردستان الايرانيه ارتكاب المجازر وسجن
النشطاء واعدامهم هي اشكال اخرى من سلوك
النظام على سبيل المثال الحجاب هو عذر
عندما يضطهد النظام سيده يقول النظام انها
فاسده على الارض يواجه النظام تهما ضد
الصحفيين على سبيل المثال قائلا لقد شنوا
حربا على الله تم تعظيم التهم من قبل
النظام بحيث يمكن ان تكون الاحكام قاسيه
هل تعتقد بان هذا النظام الحالي نظام
المرشد وحتى الحرس الثوري يعادون الاحزاب
المعارضه باعتبارها كرديه ام
يعادون فكره الانفصال فقط هل لي هذا
العداء اي علاقه بالعرق
يتعرض الاكراد لطبقات متعدده من الاضطهاد
من قبل النظام في كردستان الايرانيه اولا
نحن مطموعون من قبل النظام لمجرد كوننا
اكرادا اذا نحن مضطهدون من قبل النظام لان
مبادئنا تختلف عن مبا ما يؤمن به النظام
محدود وليس ما نناظر من اجله الشعب الكردي
في ايران بالاضافه الى التمييز القومي
والاثني والديني باضافه الى التمييز
الثقافي عندما يتعلق الامر بلغتهم الاكراد
في ايران يواجهون اضطهادا اضافيا لانهم
علمانيون وهم لا يتناسبون مع النظام منذ
ايامه الاولى كما رفضوا التصويت له
الاكراد في ايران معارضون للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لاكثر من 40 عاما
كيف ترون المرشد خمينائي وحكم المرشد
لايران حكم خانني لايران حكمه جينا مشروعه
لنزر
حكمك في ايران غير شرعي حكم ولايه الفقيه
هو في الواقع اهانه للشعب الايراني بما في
ذلك للاكراد هذه القاعده موجوده اساسا
لانها تعتقد ان الناس غير قادرين على
اداره شؤونهم لذلك يجب ان يكون شخص ما
الولي ولايه الفقيه الولي يعتبر انهم مطلق
وانه الممثل المباشر لله على الارض في مثل
هذا النظام اي شخص يخالف قوانين الولي
يعتبر عدو الله تم اعدام العديد من الشباب
الايرانيين من قبل النظام بتهمه المحاربه
هؤلاء الضحايا لم يشنوا حربا ضد الله لم
يكونوا مثل سلمان رشدي مع كتاب كانوا ضد
حكم علي خمينائي ولهذا تم التعامل معهم
كما لو كانوا ضد الله انتم اليوم تقيمون
في كردستان العراق ايران كانت
طلبت من بغداد ومن اربيل طلبات منهم
ان تبعدوا الى
معسكرات او الى مخيمات كذلك لدى الى
المطالب اخرى
تتعلق بكم كاحزاب كرديه ايرانيه معارضه هي
تقول ان على بغداد
ان تضمن ان لا تكونوا مسلحين بعد اليوم او
ان تبعدوا من كردستان العراق هل نقلت
اليكم هذه المطالب هل تحدثتم مع مسؤولين
من بغداد او اربيل
ونقلوا لكم هذه المطالب الايرانيه الرسميه
نخير
لعينك
حتى الان لم يكن هناك اتصال رسمي من بغداد
او حكومه اقليم كردستان فيما يتعلق بذلك
لم يكن هناك طلب رسمي من قبل اي من هؤلاء
بانه يجب علينا القاء اسلحتنا او سيتم
نقلنا من قاعده الى اخرى او يجب ان نغادر
هذا البلد الموضوع الوحيد الذي ابلغت عنه
بغداد وحكومه اقليم كردستان هو ان قوات
البشمركه يجب ان تنسحب من المناطق
الحدوديه وكان هذا شيئا نضعه دائما في
الاعتبار لقد اتخذنا الاجراءات المطلوبه
لتقليل الضغط على حكومه اقليم كردستان اذا
طلب منا نزع السلاح او مغادره البلاد فلن
نستسلم لهذا المطلب نزع سلاح قوتنا ليس
شيئا سنفعله لن تقبلوا هذا المطلب ما الذي
يعني هذا الامر رفض طلب حكومه بغداد او
اربيل بوضع السلاح هل يعني عمليا مواجهه
حتى مع بغداد بالريالندا
بالتاكيد نامل الا تقدم بغداد وحكومه
اقليم كردستان مثل هذا الطلب لدينا وضع
خاص في اقليم كردستان وفي الواقع لن نقبل
مثل هذا القرار لن نستسلم لقرار يريد منا
نزع السلاح والعيش حياه مدنيه تحت معسكرات
الامم المتحده نحن حزب ايراني معارض
حياتنا في خطر لدينا وضع خاص لم يتم انشاء
هذه الحاله فجاه لها تاريخ من 30 الى 40
سنه لذلك لا يمكننا قبول مثل هذا الطلب
انتم تعيشون في اقليم لديه سلطه تعيشون في
بلد لديه سياده ولديه سلطه كذلك
انطلبت منكم سلطات هذا البلد او هذا
الاقليم ان لا تكونوا مسلحين الا تكونوا
في معسكرات تدريب
هل هذا يعني انكم بعض رفض الطلب ستدخلون
او يمكن ان تدخلوا في مواجهه حتى مع بغداد
او مع السلطات الاقليم قانون النووي
ظروفي
هناك العديد من القوانين الدوليه التي
تغطي قضيتنا اذا انخرط احد الاحزاب في
صراع مع الحكومه المركزيه ثم قام الحزب
بالاخلاء الى دوله ثانيه حيث يتم قبولها
رسميا كما هو الحال بالنسبه لنا لفتره
طويله من الوقت في الواقع ستكون هناك
التزامات علينا الوفاء بها مثل عدم شن حرب
على ايران من هنا هذه هي الالتزامات التي
حققناها والواقع ان الطرف المخالف لهذا
الصراع هو الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه هي التي تهاجمنا
بالصواريخ بينما نحن متمركزون في دوله
اخرى
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هي التي تقصفنا وتزرع
الالغام وتختطف وتغتال كوادرا
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه هي التي انتهت
القانون الدولي وليس نحن لقد اوفينا
بالتزامات حالتنا الخاصه اذا كنا قد اعلنا
الحرب على ايران من هنا فان مثل هذه
المطالب من قبل بغداد واقليم كردستان
ستكون مشروعه ومع ذلك في ظل الظروف
الحاليه التي نلتزم فيها بتعهداتنا
مطالبهم غير مشروعه ولن نقبل مثل هذه
المطالب ولكن حكومه السوداني الحكومه
الجديده العراقيه هي مدعومه من الاطار
التنسيقي هل معروف دائما بانه قريب من
ايران هل مازلتم في وضع امن الان هل
تعتقدون ذلك بداخوى حكومتي عراق نبوبه
حكومه
للاسف لم يكن لدى العراق حكومه مستقره منذ
سقوط صدام لم يشهد العراق سوى حكومات
فاشله بمجرد ان تكون الحكومه المركزيه
حكومه فاشله فانها تسهل مسار التدخلات
الخارجيه في الشؤون الدوله مثل تصرفات
ايران في العراق او ظهور الجماعات
الارهابيه مثل داعش هذا الموقف يجلب لنا
مخاطر ايضا طالما ان الحكومه في بغداد
قريبه من ايران فسيكون هناك المزيد من
الضغط من بغداد ضد حكومه اقليم كردستان قد
يعني هذا المزيد من الضغط علينا ومع ذلك
نحن نتواصل مباشره مع حكومه اقليم كردستان
وليس الحكومه المركزيه نشهد ضغطا غير
مباشر من الحكومه المركزيه لكننا لا ننسق
معهم
صريحا منكم
من يدعمكم ولا اقصد الدعم القانوني او
السياسي وانما اقصد الدعم المالي الدعم
للحصول على الاسلحه
للاستمرار هنا للاقامه هنا ولانشاء مقر
للدوران حكومتكيشوا كنا متمركزين هنا خلال
فتره الحكومه العراقيه السابقه في عهد
صدام حسين تقدم لنا حكومه اقليم كردستان
دعما محدودا حتى لو كنا لاجئين سياسيين
كان ينبغي ان يكون الدعم اكثر مما نتلقاه
لا يتم دعمنا بالقدر المطلوب في جوانب
مختلفه من الحياه الخدمات والتعليم وما
الى ذلك الدعم ليس على المستوى الذي يجب
تقديمه للاجئين نحن ندعم انفسنا ماليا من
خلال مصادرنا كما اننا مدعومون من كوادر
الحزب وعائلاتهم والاكراد الوطنيين
الاسلحه التي نمتلكها تعود الى زمن الثوره
التي احتفظنا بها حتى هذا التاريخ
باستثناء الحالات الفرديه لم تلقائيه
اسلحه ولا الاحزاب الاخرى للاسف لا توجد
دوله تخطط لدعم وتسليح قوتنا علنا اليس
هناك دعم امريكي حق واب دوجمناني ايران
زورتر للاسف لابد ان اعداء الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه قد اهتموا بهذا الامر اكثر لكن
للاسف لم يدعم اعداء الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
احزاب المعارضه الايرانيه لا في المجالات
السياسيه او الاعلاميه او غيرها اعلم بان
لديكم تنسيق سياسي بين الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه المتواجده هنا في
كردستان العراق او بشكل عام في كل المهجر
لديكم لجنه مشتركه للتنسيق فيما بينكم هذا
سياسيا عسكريا هل تنسقون كذلك بينكم وكيف
مدى
ما تم انجازه هو خطوه ايجابيه لكنها ليست
ما نرغب فيه تماما اعاده توحيد ثملا
والحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني والتعاون
بينهما خطوه ايجابيه الى الامام ومع ذلك
يجب ان يتطور هذا الى وحده تلبي توقعات
الشعب الكردي لدينا خطط لتنسيق التعاون
العسكري ايضا المواقع الجغرافيه التي
تستند اليها احزابنا لا تسمح بالتنسيق
الوثيق لا تتمركز احزابنا في مكان واحد
يمكننا فيه تنسيق التدريبات العسكريه بشكل
مشترك
بالرغم من كل هذا لدينا خطط لذلك ونحن
نعمل من اجل ان تكون لكردستان الايرانيه
قوه موحده ستكون هذه القوه الموحده هي
بشميرجا كردستان وليس قوات الاحزاب
السياسيه نحن نتحرك نحو هذا الاتجاه لكننا
في المراحل الاولى من هذه العمليه كن ذكرت
منذ قليل في اجابتك السيد عبد الله بانها
حكومه كردستان العراق لم تساعدكم ولم
تتعامل معكم كرجين سياسيين ما الوضع
القانوني لكم كقاده
للاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه هنا وح فيما
يتعلق باعضاء وعناصر هذه الاحزاب ما وضع
القانوني لكم
كاتي خوي تمكن عدد محدود من كوادرنا من
الحصول على الجنسيه العراقيه في الوقت
الذي كان هناك قانون لهذا الغرض ومع ذلك
فان الحكومه الحاليه في اقليم كردستان لا
تعترف رسميا بهذه الوثائق الان هناك قانون
اخر ينص على ان اولئك الذين اصدروا هذه
الوثائق قبل عام 2005 قد تم الاعتراف
بوثائقهم لكن هذا لم يكن ممكنا الا بعد
الانتظار 17 او 18 عاما وهذا ليس بالامر
السهل بعض كوادرنا الاخرى هم من عادوا من
الشتات لديهم وثائق اقامه قانونيه يوجد
اعضاء اخرون في البلدات وقد حصلوا على
اقامتهم السياسيه البقيه وهم قوات
البشميرجا وعائلاتهم لا يملكون اي الوثائق
عراقيه للاسف هم غير موثقين لانهم ليسوا
تحت صفه اللجوء او المواطنه او الاقامه